this video didn't cost a lot of money
and he can't unwrap it and nobody had to
get trampled to 4 a.m. for you to get it
still I was thinking about you wanted to
send you a gift so here's the gift of a
puppy chewing a branch in the snow
here's the gift of a baby enjoying her
first presence here's some dancing
Santas here's the home movies of some
people we don't know celebrating
Christmas here's a gift of a gorilla
picking her nose and eating it nobody
said they were all gonna be Christmas
themed here's the gift of a Norwegian
waterfall here's the gift of Miss Terry
here's an astronaut playing guitar I'm
not sure exactly what this is but seem
like the kind of thing you might enjoy
no that's ok you're probably right if
you're my family I love you and I thank
you for everything I don't say it enough
if you're my friends thank you for
helping me with all the things I'd never
tell my family about whoever you are you
probably deserve a better gift in an
Internet video but if you think about it
gifts aren't what the holidays are
really about anyway
they're about spending time with the
people you love and reflecting on all
that's happened in the past year this
holiday season over a billion people
exchange presents it's pretty great that
against all odds I wanted up with you
happy holidays